John Caldwell is with us uh founder of
phones for you of course conservative
donor as well got a new book out um
about your autobiography love pain and
money will come to that
um so much to talk to you about first of
all welcome thank you for joining us on
the program
um you um let's talk about Ukraine to
start with should we um you do you're a
big supporter big supporter of Ukraine
yes I mean we all have to be and right
at the very beginning I was an advocate
of cutting energy purchases from Russia
now of course we all know that would
have devastating consequences for Europe
but I look at it very simplistically
which is every dollar that we pour into
Putin's hands is being used to slaughter
Ukrainian people and I I find that very
difficult to live with so I don't know
what the entire solution is to that but
we certainly should have done more to
cut supplies and to reduce energy
requirements and you've helped on a
practical level as well with offering
your home up to ukrainians yes I've got
a Ukrainian family been living with me
now for six months I did it before the
government scheme I immediately went to
find a Ukrainian family through um
through social media and got mother and
son living with me her husband's on the
front line and and of course she's got a
nice life Style with me but of course
she's devastated mentally because you
know everything that she loves is at
home and under threat
indeed so she
when you talk to her I mean what does
she talk about how does she feel she
breaks down in tears quite regularly
um
she's dealing with it quite well but you
know you can imagine being a thousand or
more miles away from home and not
knowing what's happening to your husband
every minute of the day
and all the rest of your family and
knowing that your whole life Heritage
and lifestyle is under huge threat from
a megalomaniac who's capable of anything
um it's a devastating situation to be in
and she's regularly in tears but she
also is having quite a nice life other
than that you know she's on a lovely
estate with me I managed to get her
child into school with my son uh and so
life is as normal as it can be but
there's always this huge Cloud hanging
over ahead about her Homeland yeah I'm
sure
um you come from humble beginnings what
made you decide to be a tourist
supporter
I think well I
I I did come from very working class
Beginnings but I'm very analytical and
my analysis always of the economy as the
capitalism is the only way forward but
it has to be capitalism with a heart we
have to have capitalism that grows the
economy grows it as quick as possible
and then uses that growth to help the
poorer people of society people who are
ill people who are disabled and and look
after the old age pension so all those
people in need need have to be looked
after properly and are we doing that
well we've not grown the economy and of
course the Tory party have not covered
themselves in in glory over the last
three years I'm afraid
um if they'd have employed the uh
strategy that I launched in March 2020
which was called while pandemic recovery
we've been a lot better position now and
the Tories would have something to sell
to the population that they were doing
something long term to create Britain's
long-term future to make Britain
prosperous and help save the planet as
well which was to create the Silicon
Valley of the environment somewhere in
Britain to use all sorts of incentives
to get people from all over the world to
come and locate in Britain and drive
Britain business in the environmental
space
it's a no-brainer is Liz trusting a good
job
you're supported her didn't you
no just like to correct that I did not
support reshi because he made an
absolute mess of the economy and the
time that he was in I disagreed with
nearly everything that he did it could
have all been done so much better and as
a consequence I supported the devil that
I didn't know
um and has she made a good start no I
mean it's ludicrous that they were she
was going to reduce income tax for the
well-off from 45 to 40 I mean why what
was what was the benefit of that no
benefit at all no benefit politically in
fact politically stupid would it help to
keep wealthy people on Shore no because
those people that want to escape will
escape 40 tax just as easily as 45 tax
it had no benefit to Britain whatsoever
that money could be used to invest in
Britain's economic growth which is what
I've been advocating all along let's
invest in real growth of the economy
then we can look after everybody not
just put five pence and the pound back
into rich people's pockets you made your
money
um with friends for you tell us how that
started
oh that that started because uh I wanted
a mobile phone for my car sales business
I looked at the price of a mobile phone
you could hardly buy them in those days
I mean it's bizarre now when you think
back but in 1986 to try and find a deal
or somebody who could sell your mobile
phone and the batteries were this big oh
they were huge there were suitcases
anyway I managed to buy a cup I managed
to price a couple up and the dealer
offered me one for fifteen hundred
pounds and I said well what about if I
buy two and he said 13.50 and I thought
that's a massive discount it's just for
two phones there must be a lot of money
in Mobile phones so I invited Motorola
to come and see me and I bought 26
phones which was the biggest order you
could get in those days
um unfortunately the advised me on the
right wrong mix of phones and I took
their advice because I didn't know and
those 26 phones took me eight months to
sell you know in about 10 years later I
was selling 26 phones every minute
wow okay and looking back at your career
now what what's the one tip that you
would offer to potential entrepreneurs
this morning
um well you've got to be prepared to
work extremely hard but I always say to
people analyze your skills uh really
critically you need ambition Drive
passion to hold those together you need
resilience which means you've got to
work long hours you've got to be capable
of that under extreme perhaps pressure
without cracking up and if you've got
those four qualities then it's just a
matter of how much commercial intellect
have you got what are your leadership
skills and if you do all six of those if
you've got all six of those you're
probably going to really fly but you can
do well with that with less and what I
would say to people because people out
there will be suffering now they'll be
struggling both the private individuals
but plus businesses you've just got to
keep striving and finding ways of
creating more growth creating more
profit and getting through the tough
times so that you can prosper in the
future okay I'm sure there's more about
that in the book love pain and money
when's it out now it was out on my
birthday on the 7th of October ah many
happy returns a Libra nice gentle Libra
it's nice to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you
pleasure thanks a lot